hello everyone there were a lot of great
games played in London in 1866 but this
one is the greatest
well perhaps like you be the judge of
that as usual what makes this game great
is that it's a brilliant attacking game
and it was played by William Steinitz
and a lot of people are saying you know
how Steinitz killed romantic chess how
he is the worst a very boring player but
every now and then Steinitz manages to
create a masterpiece like this even
against a player named M Hewitt the
hoodie guy I couldn't find any
information or a photo of him
unfortunately so let's see the game Hugh
it has the white pieces and he plays d4
d5 by Stein it's Bishop to c4 the
bishops opening and now f5 a very
interesting move by Stein it's today
maybe nice to see 6:00 or Knight to f6
would be preferred but Steinitz is a
student of Philidor and Philidor always
said you should always push the pawn
first to attack the center and then
develop your knight you don't want to
play Knight to f6 and then block your
own F pawn so Steinitz likes this f5 d
392 f6 and now Knight to e2 Bishop to c5
c3 preparing d4 Knight to c6
now d4 by hewitt he captures on d4
Knight captures on d4 and you don't have
to tell Stein it's twice to grab a pawn
F captures on e4 Bishop to f4 now and d5
based on its width tempo I'm the bishop
Bishop to b5 now pinning the knight and
threatening to capture on c6 Bishop
captures on d4 Queen captures on d4 and
Steinitz castles unpinning and now there
is a threat of knife captures on d4 of
course Bishop captures on c6 b captures
on c6 and this is kind of the critical
moment in the game black is somewhat
better he does have this monster pawn
chain in the center this Knight is
greatly placed on f6 the rook is on an
on an open F file the bishop is ready to
jump into the game either with g4 f5
maybe even h3
the real idea is of course Bishop to a6
to stop white from castling and watch to
figure out a plan how to how to deal
with all of this as he's not yet really
lost probably a move like c4 could be
played to you know attack the center or
maybe Knight d2 to prepare c4 at the
counter Bishop to a6 this way Bishop to
g3 comes to mind maybe maybe to get that
Bishop out of this rooks x-ray even
castling maybe but what what mr. Hewett
does isn't really isn't really something
that you would consider first of all
your queen is beautifully placed on a
nice centralized Square D 4 there is no
black piece that can kick the Queen away
from d4 black would probably have to
spend at least two moves to kick it away
I don't know maybe 97 and then c5 but
then you would then you would mess up
your own pieces just to kick the point
away from d4 so you definitely don't
want to move the Queen from d4 if you
don't have to but he won't ever leap
lays Queen to a4 with ideas of stopping
Bishop to a6 like this also he's
attacking the c6 pawn that is the base
of the pawn chain so it doesn't seem
that bad and steinitz could have jumped
into the attack right away with Knight
to g4 or maybe night to h5 rook to b8 is
also an idea
developing the rook on a nice B file
with the threat of rook capture somebody
to but steinitz considers his position
so good that he stops and defend the
pawn with Bishop to d7 and okay why not
Bishop to g5 now pinning the night and
immediately Queen to e8 unpinning and
also having some ideas of c5 expanding
in the center opening up the attack on
the Queen and here
here comes White's last blunder a move
like a move like Knights to a3 should
have been played here preparing
queenside castle or something
but why decided to play Queen to b3 and
with this move okay he's stopping c5 for
the moment
because if c5 then simply Bishop
captures row characters in Queen
captures and d5 of course but after
Queen to b3 there is a different idea
and Steinitz immediately jumps into the
attack with Knight to g4 now there is a
threat of knife captors on f2 and also
rock characters on f2 you do have to
defend this
Bishop to h4 and here is the problem
III you can't really ignore this threat
you can't capture on e3 if you capture
you get you're getting mated so here
which tries to castle here we have a
castle and the Queen to h5 now with a
temple on the bishop bishop to g3 and
now the pawn goes even further e - with
a temple on the rook rook to e1 now and
here comes the Stein it's below rook
captures on f2 and what's the idea here
well the idea is pretty simple if you
capture the rook you get Queen - H -
checkmate and this would be very
unfortunate so after rook captures an F
- Knight to d2 was played preparing
Knight to f3
so tonight we'll also join the defense
rook a to f8 Stannis doubles up on the
FF file c4 now would ideas of C captures
on d5 and also now the Queen is kind of
helping out with the defense of the king
but Steinitz doesn't give white any time
to set up and it's any sort of defense
with rook captures and g2 sacrificing
the rook we have kinky actress Angie -
and now now the monster move Queen to h3
offering after a rock now Steinitz
offers the Queen sacrifice playing like
King - h1 you get rook to f2 and there
is no defense against the rook captures
an h2 if you capture the rook
again you get Queen captures an h2
because the knight is also defending h2
so this is completely winning for black
so black a white thought he didn't
really have any options here and he
decided to accept the Queen King
captures Queen on h3 and here we have a
pretty straightforward King Hunt Knights
to e3
now blocking this G 2 square so the king
has to come up the board he can't go to
G for only square is H 4 so King 2 H 4
and we have night 2 G to check now the
bishop is slicing all the way here so
the King has to go yet further of the
board kink the g5 we have worked the f5
check King to g4 h5 check now the knight
is covering the h4 square so the King
has to go to h3 and now King to h3 with
an attack on the night and G 2 and what
do you play here for black I'm pretty
sure everyone sees you have to check the
King and also defend the night so I said
that it's a pretty straight forward King
hunt rook to f2 defending the knight and
g2 and also checkmating the white king
with the bishop on d7 so yeah they're
definitely a beautiful game if if not
the greatest played in 1866 in London
like I said you're free to free to share
your thoughts and comments about this
game it's a it's a great game and I do
hope you enjoyed it so yeah as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon